it is 5 15 on your Thursday morning are
you ready for a really really big
teeny tiny art show well it's the
international market of miniature
Artisans and our Lauren degretty is at
the Gold Coast at Flamingo and Valley
View with a big look at the small stuff
hey Lauren
hey good morning guys I picked these up
special for you uh just kidding it's an
Arctic structure but look at that detail
here some of the many things to check
out at this mini show with me I've got
one of the artists here Jordan Alfonso
with Euler's Workshop now you do some
cityscapes here different stuff also
going to be for sale this weekend but
talk to me about how this got started
yeah when I was seven and I saw Star
Wars for the first time it was explained
to me that most of the special effects
were actually Miniatures made by people
and that kind of blew my mind and ever
since then I've been trying to figure it
out for myself that's amazing and like
you said that some of these have
actually been used for some superhero
promotions that's interesting yeah
different companies have hired me to
make stuff for commercials and for
advertising work and that's been a lot
of fun definitely Spider-Man on top of
these uh water towers here but you've
also got a a collaborative project as
well now this isn't for sale but I think
we'll recognize the Mandalorian themes
here yeah it's inspired by Star Wars and
we've got 20 different artists from six
different countries that all contributed
and volunteered their time to make this
giant art piece for everyone to do enjoy
super duper interesting here and this
this part though we should mention is
not for sale no it's not for sale it's
just for people to come and enjoy and
check out what these artists did it's a
very interesting detail so again all
this is in display uh this week and then
come this weekend this special uh thing
here is that you can actually purchase
the other things over in this area here
we're going to have more art coming up
for you to enjoy for now live in Las
Vegas Lauren negretti 8 News Now
stuff
I'm a teeny tiny Tatooine
that's a true art form isn't it yes yes
it's a skill it's a big skill yeah yeah
to scale it down but then also to get
the detail right look real closely you
can see all the little detail of like on
on that spaceship you know of oh sure
pilots and the Machinery our own
Caroline Blakely I don't know if you
know this but her daughter in New York
makes matures she designs sets
and she does set design miniature for
staging and design yeah yeah I did not
know that what she does for a living
very talented